um also joining us from texas
is karl rove he's right here on the
couch he's a contributor he's a former
deputy chief of staff to president
george w bush he's a resident of texas
the perfect guest to come in and tell us
what's happening in texas it's a mess
that's what's happening democrats want
no part of this story none none and it's
amazing to me the the government has an
obligation to tell us what it's doing
and you'll notice nobody has come out
and said here's what we're doing here's
how many we sent back to haiti here's
how many we're distributing inside the
united states here's the reason why
we're taking some people and returning
them and the reason why we're allowing
some people to remain in the united
states we have found out however
normally what they do is is they take
and they say you're here illegally but
the reasons that that allow you to
remain here but we're going to give you
a court date right instead they're now
saying here's a notice to appear before
uh uh border patrol agents right which
does not carry with it the same kind of
penalties of course it's
them to make tell them when to come to
court i mean we don't it's impossible
people pete xs was just on earlier carl
he said that you know these flights are
going out to into the interior of the
country with these illegal immigrants
haitian and otherwise flights yeah ice
flights exactly in the middle of the
night so there there's your transparency
for you if it was all on the up and up
why wouldn't happen in the middle of the
day why don't we know the numbers i i
don't i don't make much of the middle of
the night because they process them
during the day and they may launch the
flight at seven o'clock or eight o'clock
or one o'clock in the morning but
they're just trying to get them but we
need to know yeah and and and you'll
notice yesterday senator johnson from
your home state you want to see yeah
absolutely exchange that got everyone
frustrated except for mayorkus himself
listen
how many people have been returned
how many people are being detained how
many people have been dispersed to all
points around america
senator i would be pleased to provide
you with that debt i want them now
why don't you have that information now
uh senator i do not have that debt why
not me why don't you add that basic
information
well carl uh it's basic the secretary
doesn't want to admit the numbers they
know the numbers bill malugen sent out a
tweet uh yesterday and he said according
to texas department of uh public safety
as of this morning there were 332
husband wife combinations where the wife
is pregnant under the bridge in del rio
now here's we're going to break down the
numbers and figure this out all right uh
the there were 6 700 family units we
know the government the you know the
biden administration gonna let them in
uh 1500 single males they're gonna have
to go back 493 single females they get
to stay too
yeah and remember this number is
constantly changing because it's not
like we have a static group of you know
14 000 people there they're they're
constantly flowing across the border
constantly being either returned to
haiti or more likely released into the
united states and and
let's go back to the beginning of this
though why are all the haitians who have
been by and large throughout central and
south america for much of the past year
why are they now showing up there's some
kind of an organized effort there and if
we got to the bottom of it i would not
be surprised if we're not the cartel
saying hey you're haitian guess what
they're going to do this status you need
us it's going to let you in give us a
thousand dollars give us 2 000 we'll
help you get up there and you'll be
you'll be home free well carl that's
because in may the administration gave
them a
temporary protected status for another
18 months right because of the
earthquake and came 22 years ago yeah
can i ask you a question so a lot of
people speculate that the reason why the
biden administration has essentially
opened our borders is that they think in
in the way they believe in open borders
but b that in the future they will
benefit politically from all these new
immigrants who are illegal immigrants
who will eventually be voters my
question to you because you know the
politics texas is a hotly debated a
hotly contested
state
a lot of democrats dream of taking texas
what are the politics in texas of this
are there enough migrants to turn that
or are they turning off democrats in
such great numbers that it's not going
to benefit physics i think it's a newton
law for every action there's an opposite
nuclear reaction just remember what are
the counties in america that moved more
dramatically towards the republicans in
2020 as compared to 2016 and you'll find
a bunch of them are the heavily hispanic
counties along the rio grande river part
of it was energy because a lot of those
people work in the energy business but a
lot of it was wait a minute it's our
communities who are being adversely
affected first by illegal immigration
you know it's our hospitals it's our
social services it's our compassion it's
the safety of our neighborhoods that's
being affected and that was a big reason
why a lot of
tejanos said you know what i'm voting
republican because there's they're
saying we ought to have a border we came
here legally or we came through a
process these people are not and they're
they're they're they're hurting our
communities
56
of texas uh residents were asked uh
hispanic texas hispanic residents were
asked about the performance of president
biden 56 disapproved of his performance
in uh in texas that's not a good sign if
you want to make if you want to turn
texas blue no and look
we got robert francis o'rourke getting
ready to run for governor he is about as
far left-wing as you can he will not be
well received in a generally
conservative community that is
pro-family pro-life pro-military
pro-america pro-small business pro
enterprise
this is a lot of money
we'll see there are real consequences
though i have a friend who lives in
mission texas who says that
the hospitals are absolutely overwhelmed
and that american children are having to
travel a hundred miles away to corpus
christi to get in terms of the services
in their local hospitals are filled with
with with uh illegal immigrants
absolutely true i was in corpus christi
not too long ago and somebody said you
know we got a lot of people coming up
here for elective surgery at our
hospitals because they can't be taken
care of in edinburgh or mcallen or
brownsville or harlingen you know um so
donald trump pretty much stopped the
flow
you know at the end of his
administration then joe biden turned it
back on
obviously when you're the president you
can you've got vast uh power over how
the laws the united states are
implemented but ultimately if people
want to get anything changed and and
when you were in the bush administration
george bush tried to get immigration
reform done
and you know for a variety of reasons he
couldn't even get his own party to do
well it wasn't a it wasn't our own his
own party that killed it it was
president barack obama and then senator
obama who promised to support
comprehensive immigration reform right
voting for all of the killer amendments
offered by democratic senator dorgan of
of of north dakota helped by senator
harry reid so just a need to get to the
reconciliation right yeah well so how do
we fix it it's got to come well first
you've got to stop you've got to start
by border security it took us four years
or almost five years to end catch and
release to get in place all of the
processes necessary to say to people if
you come here you're not going to be
able to be released out into society and
and escape consequences so first thing
you've got to do is secure the border
that's why it is smart for governor
abbott to say if the federal government
will not spend the money to build the
wall we'll spend two billion dollars of
of texas money to build the wall and the
unfinished places in order to get better
control over border and it's why texas
is spending tens if not hundreds of
millions of dollars every biennium for
additional law enforcement along the
border because it's our community that's
being affected and the federal
government under this administration
will not step up and do the job that
it's responsible for that drone team has
put more pressure on the biden
administration than anything else
because no one can deny that
young reporter at the white house named
peter ducey who keeps asking questions
they don't want to ask convenient
questions who is that guy anyway where
did he come from he's got some really
good hair i'm just saying
carl thank you very much you bet great
to see you
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now